what was the problem with the big bang
well there's a lot of problems with a
big bang that begins with an infinite
temperature Singularity for one thing
how did it get to be a baly 23° c today
how did it get from infinite anything to
finite something it's a great mystery
furthermore the question of how can
something spontaneously come into
existence without any seeming cause
first mover as the Greeks would call it
these scientists including the great sir
Fred Hoy who coined the term Big Bang he
coined it allegedly as a pejorative I
won't say for what because my kids are
in the audience but allegedly you Brits
have a spicy sense of humor one of the
reasons he didn't like it is echoed by
the great and unfortunately late Steven
Weinberg he said the following he said
the steady state model which was
preferred by Jeffrey Burbage by Sir Fred
Hoy and many many other great scientists
is preferable because it least resembles
the account of Genesis 1 what does
Genesis 1:1 say in America we can't talk
about this in public no we we can but
but we usually don't in the beginning
what does that mean the beginning of
what the beginning of God's creating of
the universe fine but there was a
beginning in the biblical narrative what
Weinberg is saying is that's
distasteful and he wished for a long
time that there could be an alternative
the most attractive of which was the
steady state universe but we knew the
universe couldn't be steady because it
was expanding and so the great hoil
Burbage and others appended a couple of
acronym letters in front and called it
the Quasi steady state cosmology
QSC that held sway for a long
time but the main reason that Drew many
of scientists to find the Big Bang
distasteful was that it resembled a
theological explanation so as I like to
say if you don't have a big bang you
don't have a big banger if you don't
have a big bang there's no need for as
an atheist would call it some
Supernatural Force some fairy tale Etc
you can get around that if the universe
is there forever of course a religiously
inclined person might say well God has
been there forever so there's usually
not much Headway that can be made that
was until the discovery in
1965 in New Jersey of all places so I'm
a New Yorker
so so I can make fun of New Jersey uh
and there was this paper published and
the paper's title is the most
understated in all of history I said a
det an excess of antenna temperature at
480 megacycles per second you wouldn't
think that that would be such a
revolutionary just completely Paradigm
shifting headline for a paper that was
perhaps the first and most precise
evidence for a potentially singular
origin of the universe and yet it was
and it was a black body what is a black
body a black body is a thermal radiation
Source I going to have the wonderful Isa
out here tonight please Isa give her a
round of applause as she sets up our
black body
demonstration this will be
echoing echoing no pun intended the
great experiment of Humphrey Davy who
would take gunpowder and use it and
ignite it using thermal radiation which
is invisible but can be used to
demonstrate the propagation of heat at
the same rate that light ordinary light
propag Gates and what we will do tonight
is transmit at the speed of light
thermal radiation from one end of the
room to the other they used to do that
with a red hot Cannonball uh We've
cooled them off uh and we now use a
black body source so thank you Isa and
we will start this now so this is a
crude telescope that will transmit at
the speed of light a black body of
almost a th000 degre above absolute zero
are you ready so you may want to Shield
your ears or protect your ears I'm told
let me do it on this side so I don't
block The View okay are you ready cover
your ears if you're sensitive to sound
this is a literal trigger
warning how about
[Applause]
that so what the Great Kus and Wilson
did back in New Jersey in
1965 was to demonstrate that the
Universe had a background of heat
nowhere near as hot as this fiery
demonstration just revealed but
nevertheless it was buzzing with
microwave energy that we can still
detect today a fossil relic of the
synthesis of the lightest elements on
the periodic table that Sir Humphrey
Davy knew well indeed in fact it has a
perfect black body Spectrum so perfect
that no human-made object can have a
spectrum anywhere near as close to that
that mother nature provides to us an
exquisitely precise and accurately
measured depiction of thermal radiation
this was interpreted as the Afterglow of
the creation of the elements resulting
from an age of the universe of about
380,000 years the universe had cooled
off from those fiery temperatures needed
to cause nuclear fusion to proceed down
to a baly 3,000 k warmer than even
Humphrey would get these black bodies up
to and in the preceding 13.8 billion
years the universe is cooled off so that
this radiation now bathes us at a frosty
2.7 or 3° kelvin so looking out in to
space we are looking back into time and
the question for many many decades even
not settled when I began graduate school
was was the background of heat that
surrounds us was it featureless or was
it filled with the imprint of fossil
pertubations in SpaceTime itself and
these were measured and then eventually
depicted on this beach ball over here
this is a God's eye view of the universe
looking down instead of a picture of
constellations this is going Way Beyond
the realm of our galaxy Way Beyond the
realm of even the galaxies that we see
and have talked about already back to
the formation of the first atoms in the
universe the form of hydrogen and its
Isotopes and by looking at this pattern
we see several features first we see
this orange line around the middle that
is the Milky Way
galaxy and that will play a very very
important role in the rest of this talk
because this is a dirty window through
which we must look through now in
reality we're sort of in the center of
this beach ball but that would be pretty
expensive to put each one of you in a
beach ball and rather rude so we didn't
do that but this is as I say looking at
as sort of an omniscient deity would see
it question is how did these
fluctuations in the amount of energy in
the amount of matter in the amount of
dark matter how did those arise where
did they come from and that's what the
main thesis of What's called the
inflationary Universe purports to answer